what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to wuski
computers remix clout boys
official video by chicago ebk
before i start you already know
subscribe to the channel and bring the
notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos
okay i'm going to make this full screen
oh my gosh i like the piano that sounds
[Music]
good
[Applause]
[Music]
okay um i'd like to start by saying
the decor in this house i'm not
impressed by like at all like these
walls look very plain
so um i know you guys have been telling
me these are called like trap houses and
they don't care what
what it looks like but i don't
understand why if you're gonna have a
trap house why not make it homey
why not
why not like where you're staying
do they have like okay you know when
there's like um
in frat houses there's like like a frat
house mom
are there trap house moms that's my real
question
because i think i'd be very good at it
i'm gonna like i can cook
i can clean
um anyways so on top of that
they are talking a lot of [ __ ] they're
like
talking about how good they are with
weapons i'm going to continue
[Music]
[ __ ] opposition
[Music]
what is he just said a lot of letters
that i don't know what those mean don't
you rephrase them
don't you do it don't you do it
don't i do baby rephrase
what those lettuce why
leave them alone okay apparently i can't
say the letters
i've been given rules out here for my
channel
what the [ __ ]
what is people's obsession with o block
i don't understand they say fo block
it's like either people love oblock or
they hate old block i don't know what's
going on this block
but it sounds like some people threw a
party and other people like weren't
invited that's what i think happened
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'd like to say okay i feel like they're
talking a lot of [ __ ] about how they
have like
they're really good with the weapons um
they're like cooler than other people
but i just want to talk about the style
here
i'm just not impressed like what are we
doing with the zip up hoodie
like what we what is this the early
2000s with the sparkles on here
but they really like do not like their
oppositions like
they have a bone to pick is really what
i'm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so they talk about shooting to kill
and they teach that
in like self-defense and like police
training
that if you shoot at somebody like
you're not shooting for their
hand or anything like trying to like
damage them a little bit you you're
shooting to kill so he's taking this
seriously you know what i mean they
terrified [ __ ] telling
me
[Music]
this grill for real
[Music]
i just got a brand
[Music]
[Applause]
that was clever i got a brand new glock
i got a brand new
op so we seen i got so does that mean
every time he buys a gun
he gets a new up like there's a new
person that he wants to like
go after or like beef with you already
know what it is
what does he mean he says i don't want
to talk you've been talking this whole
song
like what do you mean this is what
you've been doing
[Music]
[Music]
his ass cause he was running too slow
hallucinating up this white white right
now i'm losing it
lost three times all my [ __ ] married
to shooting [ __ ]
now who the [ __ ] wanna go to war with
some lunatic
okay so he is letting people know that
he does not deal with snitches
and snitching is the worst form
of like like if i've learned anything
from these songs
is that people do not appreciate like a
tattletail
basically so i can understand that like
when i was growing up i did not
appreciate it when my siblings snitched
on me so i could see
why they wouldn't like that now i don't
think i would recommend like the gun
part i would recommend like
talking it out you know but that's just
me spreading green beans like it's
christmas don't want looking suspicious
cause we don't shoot from no distance or
we don't do sneak disses
in the kitchen water whipping them [ __ ]
we steady flipping
golden shoot like scottie pimping that's
bigger what we sipping
[Music]
[Music]
with that
[Music]
[Applause]
oh dear they said they're putting them
in a trunk
do people actually do the stuff that
they put in the songs
oh my goodness
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so he's saying that he's gonna do
whatever he wants and the police cannot
stop him
so he's saying f the cops because he's
gonna do what he wants
he's got a 50 like 50 shots so i think
he's going to take like 50 shots on his
gun
maybe in like a certain like probably in
the ops block well he'll take like 50
shots
[Applause]
[Music]
and listen he's reiterating his point
he's saying we don't care about
talking like i'm action i will shoot
[Applause]
i'd like to say i have not been
impressed by the dance moves
in this video um like i just i feel like
i could do these i'm not even gonna lie
to you
okay um what did i think of this video
i actually liked the piano a lot in the
beginning and i liked like the beat of
this video
so i'm gonna give it a three out of five
um which is just like average like
people think three out of five is bad
but it's just like
average to me uh let me know in the
comments what you guys would rank this
song out of five
and do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring the notification bell
i will talk to you guys next time